production designer role is changing
because our tools are changing like
crazy the change in technology has had
this to my mind a fundamental liberation
of the creative process we collectively
the filmmakers have raised the
expectations of the audiences to such a
level that more and more is expected as
visual effects are changing the demands
of sets are changing dramatically it's
like the opportunities for visual
extravaganza now are unlimited everyone
believes we can do everything overnight
it's moving very rapidly generally they
generally the job is similar but they
way in which you would pack it is can be
very very different every time I come
into a job where more and more computer
graphics are used it's a different thing
than the last time technology definitely
has its learning curve not only what the
uses of these new techniques are and
what their limitations are but we also
have to know how to blend them most
immediate change is through the internet
and the speed in which we're expected to
do things I think it's been a great tool
for research ebay has been good i use
ebay a lot when I'm when I'm shopping
for a movie digital photography has
helped us our assistants can communicate
imagery faster to us the internet is a
wonderful tool to be able to research
from your office gaining information to
help you understand the project that you
are doing is so much easier the easier
part of course is having my database all
in one place so that I know how to find
resources the harder part is the speed
with which things are being generated
and the amount of email I get its
enormous there's so many more emails and
so much more communication that it's
really hard to keep up everybody is now
looking into the computer so long that
they forgotten what peripheral vision is
and for me when I wanted in a film I
want to be inside the film and I think
we spend too much time looking in the
box we used to have
think more more prep time and we we
needed it pain only dries so fast and an
exacto knife only cuts cardboard so fast
and it almost gave you a chance while
you were doing it to think many people
seem to think that because technology's
there the work is easier and that the
work can go faster I feel as though the
work sometimes you need a little time to
figure out the ideas that are inside the
work you still need that time to breathe
and really digest what you're doing and
and not only be iterative with your
collaborators but with yourself you just
need to be able to stare at objects and
the ideas in the script and nothing's
gonna really speed my brain up any
faster so you do need some time to
figure out what what you're doing the
speed at which computer technology
changes is always a challenge for
everyone because as I said it's very
difficult to know when you leave one job
and when by the time you start another
one exactly how they how the rules are
going to shift when I first started
making movies we would just figure out
the sets and from a drawing and we would
just build the sets and dress the sets
now there is so much preparation that
goes before you even start filming
there's a huge responsibility now for
the designer to literally design the
production before they start designing
the objects that the narrative spaces
that exists within the production the
requirements of what a set decorator
does varies from project to project it's
a constantly evolving question of how do
we meld it into the existing framework
of the structure of our jobs in a way
they have have been there's almost no
relation between what a designer's job
was 10 years ago five years ago even and
what it will be in five and ten years
where do you use that technology and who
makes the decisions about
where it gets used and how how each
department is going to be woven into
that fabric it's it's a constantly
evolving question it really is like a
Herrick lydian River you never know when
one job ends how different the next
one's going to end up being I've learned
a great deal over in the past decade
alone regarding all the new technologies
but I think it really hasn't changed the
way that I do my job twenty years ago
when i started the possibilities of film
were so exciting then and now with
digital media there is so much to play
with there are so many new collaborators
so many new ways of collaborating I the
more the merrier and the technology that
hasn't even arrived yet and very excited
about
you